[Musik]
ein ziel viele meinungen in der korona
krise sucht deutschland den richtigen
weg vom stillstand zurück zur normalität
zwei länder zwei entscheidungen während
in österreich viele geschäfte wieder
öffnen verlängert frankreich seine
strengen ausgangs regeln und einsatz am
terrassen tisch soldaten der bundeswehr
tauschen panzer gegen wäsche wagen um
überlasteten pflegeheimen zu helfen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem dienstag nach ostern schön dass
sie dabei sind
wir beginnen mit der frage die alle
umtreibt wann und wie werden die
einschränkungen gelockert die kanzlerin
und die ministerpräsidenten beraten zwar
erst morgen aber schon heute wurde
deutlich die lage ist fragil und komplex
in jedem bundesland anders und
entsprechend verschieden sind die
strategien patricia mayr heute morgen in
der uniklinik gießen der
gesundheitsminister und der hessische
ministerpräsident wollen sich vor ort
ein bild machen und lernen immer noch
dazu verspannt maske ist verkehrt
in der debatte um den lockdown ist
gesundheitsminister sparen einer der
ersten der sich für eine vorsichtige
lockerung der maßnahmen ausspricht wenn
in bestimmte bereiche des einzelhandels
zeigen können dass das geht so wie die
supermärkte ist uns ja auch zeigen jeden
tag das ist geht dann kann man das
sicherlich auch auf andere bereiche im
einzelhandel übertragen eine vorsichtige
lockerung das empfehlen auch die
wissenschaftler der leopoldina in halle
eine lockerung nicht nur für kleinere
geschäfte sondern auch für schuhe
grundschulen und die sekundarstufe eins
also bis zur zehnten klasse dürften
schrittweise wieder öffnen so der rat er
ist in der fachwelt und politik
umstritten
ich halte die empfehlungen der
leopoldina für eine unter vielen bin ich
der auffassung dass das in allen
bereichen überzeugt ich bin schon gar
nicht der auffassung dass ist überzeugt
bereich der grundschule
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass wir
diesen weg gehen werden keine
alleingänge ein einheitliches vorgehen
aller 16 länder fordert der
nordrhein-westfälische ministerpräsident
mit wenigen ausnahmen nrw zum beispiel
will nach den osterferien die schulen
schrittweise wieder öffnen um zumindest
abschluss prüfungen durchführen zu
können wir haben andere abitur termine
als andere länder
wir haben andere ferientermine als
andere
also hier brauchen wir eine flexibilität
in grundsätzlicher übereinstimmung und
die opposition sie fordert erst einmal
die voraussetzungen für eine lockerung
zu schaffen genügend schutzkleidung
genügend tests und im zweifelsfall eben
auch genügend personal noch ist keine
klare linie erkennbar
nur der berliner regierende
bürgermeister hat schon mal angekündigt
das vor ende april in der hauptstadt
nicht mit lockerungen zu rechnen sei und
lockerungen gibt es ja bekanntlich nur
wenn die regeln eingehalten werden mit
abstand halten hat es bei politikern und
ärzten heute in gießen nicht so
funktioniert theo koll in berlin
eines zeichnet sich schon ab es wird
wohl keine einheitlichen lockerungen
geben oder
darauf sieht es jedenfalls aus das
nordrhein westfalens schulministerin ja
schon heute angekündigt hat dass sie die
schulen nach den osterferien
schrittweise öffnen will
klingt dann doch etwas nachdem
überbietungswettbewerb von dem wir
eigentlich alle gesagt haben dass hin
vermeiden wollen wenn man sich hier um
hört in berlin und bei den verschiedenen
landesregierungen dann heißt es sehr oft
man wolle morgen zumindest versuchen
einen gemeinsamen fahrplan zu erarbeiten
also festzulegen was vorrangig gelockert
bzw geöffnet werden soll das aber
durchaus mit regionalen unterschieden
weil natürlich auch die bedingungen in
den bundesländern unterschiedlich sind
zu rechnen glaube ich ist mit einer
aussage zu schulen und auch der
einzelhandel könnte sofern dort
besondere hygiene eingehalten werden
kann morgen eine art öffnungs
perspektive bekommen insgesamt gilt
sicher keine rückkehr zur normalität
sicher unterschiedliche lösungen aber
vielleicht ein einheitlicher maßstab für
künftige lockerungen morgen wissen wir
es genau vielen dank für diese ersten
einschätzungen theo koll aus berlin
wir schauen uns nochmal die schulen
genauer an
da haben die experten der
wissenschaftsakademie leopoldina ja
folgendes empfohlen zuerst die jüngeren
wieder zum unterricht zu lassen von der
ersten bis zur zehnten klasse in
kleineren festen lerngruppen mit bis zu
15 schülern und alle mit mundschutz
viele fragen sich das skeptisch
wie das klappen soll dort bewerber hat
sich umgehört noch lernen mika und henry
zu hause bald aber könnte es wieder
unterricht in der schule geben teilweise
jedenfalls und mit strengen abstands und
hygieneregeln
ihre mutter ist erst mal skeptisch wenn
sie sich sehen nach fünf wochen dann
werden die sich erst mal alle
abklatschen umarmen freuen und wenn man
dann auf dem schulhof sagen muss ein
fußball dürfte nicht spielen und ihr
dürft auch immer nur zwei meter oder ein
meter fünfzig haid auseinander stehen
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen dass die
sich daran halten
die schulen bereiten sich jedenfalls vor
an diesem gymnasium in mönchengladbach
mit neuen desinfektions spendern
sie rechnen mit kleinen schülergruppen
etwa einer halben klassenstärke und
weniger leistungskontrollen dass die
politik hier auch jetzt sieht dass wir
nicht alle klassen arbeiten und alle
klausuren hinbekommen werden wer aber
soll als erstes zur schule kommen die
wissenschaftler der leopoldina plädieren
für die kleinen die nicht so gut mit
digitalem unterricht zurechtkommen
dem widerspricht das robert koch
institut wir denken dass es apple ii
biologisch sehr viel sinn macht erst die
älteren in der schule wieder zu öffnen
richtig und wichtig sei es auf jeden
fall die schulen wieder allmählich zu
öffnen sagt der lehrer verband
sie war keine notwendigkeit jüngere
schüler sozusagen gegen ältere schüler
aus zu spielen oder umgekehrt wenn dann
muss überlegt werden wie an allen
schulen und allen schularten für
einzelne jahrgangsstufen der unterricht
wieder schrittweise beginnen kann
eine woche vorlauf aber bräuchten die
schulen selbst für eine teilweise
öffnung die positive nachricht vom
robert koch institut heute ja die
maßnahmen wirken aber und das ist einer
der entscheidenden punkte
es gibt noch immer keine hinweise darauf
dass corona eingedämmt ist steffen logan
stand mit die neuesten zahlen
stand 18 30 sind in deutschland laut
johns hopkins universität fast 130 1700
corona infektionen durch test bestätigt
als genießen geld mehr als 68.000
menschen 3261 starben in verbindung mit
dem virus
die ausbreitung verlangsamt sich anfang
märz hatte sich die zahl der erkrankten
noch alle zwei tage verdoppelt nun sind
es über 25
eine zwischenbilanz des nac wir haben
eines unserer ziele bereits erreicht
ein wichtiges ziel wir haben die grippe
welle von der kogit 19 welle entkoppelt
das ist nämlich deshalb wichtig weil
dadurch viele betten und zwei
intensivbetten in den krankenhäusern zur
verfügung stehen
gleichzeitig nannte der chef des lka
neue wichtige zahlen
die infizierten sind im schnitt 49 jahre
alt drei von vier haben husten fieber
und schnupfen
aber auch von geschmacks und geruchs
verlust wird berichtet 16 prozent müssen
im krankenhaus behandelt werden
bei zwei prozent diagnostizieren ärzte
eine lungenentzündung die
sterblichkeitsrate liegt bei 2,4 prozent
die zahl der todesfälle steigt jedoch
mit zunehmenden alter besonders
betroffen ist hier die gruppe der 80 bis
89 jährigen
insgesamt betrachtet schwächen sich aber
die kogit 19 infektionen ab das heißt
die getroffenen maßnahmen wirken und das
sind gute nachrichten
und ich möchte noch mal sagen das haben
wir allen bürgern und bürgerinnen zu
verdanken
jedoch gilt weiterhin piene und distanz
halten noch reichen die zahlen nicht
dafür aus dauerhaft entwarnung zu geben
die pressekonferenz des robert koch
instituts finden sie in voller länge in
unserer zdf heute app dort gibt es auch
alle aktuellen zahlen aus deutschland
aber auch im weltweiten vergleich
mehrere länder in europa lockern ihre
krone maßnahmen in dänemark zum beispiel
machen kindergärten und grundschulen
wieder auf in italien erste
fachgeschäfte und auch beim nachbarn
österreich darf wieder mehr eingekauft
werden in kleinen leben unter 400
quadratmeter fläche und in baumärkten ab
anfang mai sollen dann alle geschäfte
auch friseure wieder öffnen mitte mai
könnten lokale und restaurants
folgen vorausgesetzt die zahl der
neuinfektionen bleibt unter kontrolle
aus wien wolf christian ulrich
riesenschlange heute morgen vor diesem
baumarkt in wien alle tragen masken die
einkaufswagen werden desinfiziert sowie
österreich die wirtschaft wieder in gang
bringen
wir haben wir jetzt zwei wochen lang
unter badezimmer unter wasser gesetzt
und jetzt habe ich einen neuen
tiefschlag natürlich freut man sich dass
es ein stück freiheiten auch dazu dass
man gewinnt das war das highlight des
tages auf jeden fall highlight der
quarantäne gesetzt
neben den baumärkten durften heute vor
allem die kleineren geschäfte eröffnen
in diesem blumenladen deshalb große
erleichterung
ich freue mich richtig dass wir wieder
da sein dürfen weil mir einfach der
kontakt zu unseren kunden auch schon ein
bisschen gefehlt hat
zu den auflagen gehören ab heute abstand
also nur ein kunde auf 20 quadratmeter
verkaufsfläche und masken pflicht nicht
nur in den geschäften auch im
öffentlichen nahverkehr
nach dem kleinen geschäften heute so
sieht es der korona fahrplan vor sollen
am zweiten mai auch die übrigen
geschäfte öffnen mitte mai dann
gastronomie und hotels vier wochen
lockdown nach angaben des iwf könnte die
österreichische wirtschaft dadurch 7
prozent schrumpfen
die arbeitslosenzahlen aktuell auf
historischem höchststand trotzdem locker
die bundesregierung die maßnahmen nur
mit angezogener handbremse sollten sich
die zahlen in die falsche richtung
entwickeln dann werden wir
selbstverständlich die notbremse ziehen
willkommen zurück plakatieren heute
viele geschäfte dass die zahl der korona
kranken in österreich deutlich sinkt
gibt grund für optimismus die rückkehr
zum alltag aber nur schritt für schritt
so will man einen rückfall unbedingt
vermeiden
anderes bild in frankreich dort müssen
sich die bürger noch länger gedulden
die regierung hat ihre strengen
ausgangssperren bis zum 11 mai
verlängert heißt weitere vier wochen
lang darf nur aus wer einkaufen oder zum
arzt muss zur arbeit gehen darf nur wer
das nachweislich nicht von zu hause kann
hunde ausführen bleibt erlaubt gestern
wandte sich der präsident wieder direkt
ans volk
dritten mal in dieser krise aus paris
thomas walde frankreich erlebte einen
neuen präsidenten im manual makro sprach
nicht mehr vom krieg gegen das virus
sondern zeigte verständnis für die
belastung der menschen und räumte
versäumnisse ein
juni waren wir vorbereitet auf diese
krise offensichtlich nicht genug sein
wie ehrlich sie hat lücken und schwächen
offenbart ariel edv und auch makros
ankündigungen für die zeit nach der
ausgangssperre zeigen dass einige
defizite wohl bleiben werden am 11
mai haben wir die kapazität alle
menschen zu testen die symptome zeigen
wir werden nicht alle französinnen und
franzosen testen das macht keinen sinn
doch auch menschen ohne symptome können
das virus übertragen frankreich hat also
weiter ein problem mit testen muss mit
unsicherheit leben reaktionen auf macros
rede
meine befürchtung und die meiner
kollegen ist dass die in asien nach
aufhebung der ausgangssperre
das virus zurück kommt und hier den
krankenhäusern eine zweite welle erleben
makro kündigt ein ende der
ausgangssperre ab dem 11 feiern aber
ohne planung und bedingungen ist das
extrem gefährlich modul schrittweise
solle das land so makro aus der
ausgangssperre entlassen werden deutlich
wurde aber auch frankreich wird selbst
nach dem 11 mai gegen das virus und
einige defizite kämpfen müssen
in die usa dort reagiert präsident jump
zunehmend dünnhäutig auf kritik an
seinem krisenmanagement kritische medien
seien das eigentliche problem in der
korona krise behauptet er und legt sich
gleichzeitig mit den bundesstaaten an
nicht sie sondern allein er habe zu
entscheiden ob maßnahmen gegen die
epidemie gelockert würden oder nicht
im at wissen aus washington donald trump
ist stolz auf sich und sein pr video
premiere in der offiziellen
pressekonferenz säuberlich montiert all
seine leistungen das sollten die medien
bitte berichten stadt zu behaupten er
habe gezögert und versagt aber es fehlen
wochen zwischen dem 6 februar und 2 märz
was haben sie im februar gemacht viel
wir geben ihnen eine liste und ein teil
war ja gerade zu sehen
aber da war doch ein loch sie wissen
dass sie ein fake sind sowie ihr sender
tatsächlich hatte trump nachdem ein
reisestopp aus china die gefahr wochen
lang weiter verharmlost obwohl die
experten intern drastische maßnahmen
voll deshalb zu sagen kritiker seien die
krankenhäuser so überfordert fehle es an
schutzkleidung und seien die opferzahlen
höher als sie hätten sein müssen
derweil will der präsident das
wirtschaftsleben im land wieder in gang
bringen und glaubt dass er allein das
entscheidet wenn jemand der präsident
der vereinigten staaten ist ist eine
autorität total
so wird es sein total total das wissen
die gouverneure
die gouverneure im westen und osten des
landes darunter ein republikaner haben
sich aber verständigt selbst zu
entscheiden egal was der präsident sagt
sie berufen sich auf die verfassung
die bundesregierung hat nicht die
absolute macht wir haben keinen könig
trump wir haben präsident tram der bei
stehen menschen die ihre arbeit verloren
haben schlange an den kostenlosen
lebensmittelausgaben und hoffen dass die
wirtschaft wieder anläuft möglichst bald
wegen der korona krise will die türkei
rund 90.000 häftlinge freilassen das
wäre etwa jeder dritte insasse der
völlig überfüllten gefängnisse
ausgenommen sind aber politische
gefangene die nach den umstrittenen anti
terror gesetzen angeklagt wurden
also auch menschenrechtler oder
kritische journalisten in den türkischen
gefängnissen sitzen derzeit auch 62
deutsche 1
die virus krise ist auch eine
wirtschaftskrise
neue schlechte prognosen kommen vom
internationalen währungsfonds der iwf
erwartet für 2020 eine globale rezession
die weltweite wirtschaftsleistung könnte
den experten zufolge um drei prozent
schrumpfen
für die eurozone wird sogar ein minus
von 7,5 prozent vorausgesagt die lage
sei schlimmer als in der finanzkrise
2008 2009 so der iwf und mit dieser mehr
als schwierigen lage muss auch eine
deutsche schlüsselbranche kämpfen der
maschinenbau made in germany
erfolgsverwöhnt jetzt ist fast über
nacht alles anders die produktion stockt
und vielleicht noch viel bedrohlicher
lieferketten reißen und märkte brechen
weg sven glas und rolf peter weißhaar
haben recherchiert die produktionshallen
leer wie selten bei diesem hersteller
von hochpräzisions werkzeugen in
tübingen nur etwa jeder fünfte
mitarbeiter kommt derzeit in den betrieb
die anderen sind zuhause bauen
überstunden ab oder nehmen urlaub
aufträge und auch umsätze eingebrochen
wir warten zumindest für das zweite
quartal in dem wir uns bewegen
einen rückgang in einer größenklasse von
rund 50 prozent für dieses jahr werden
wir wahrscheinlich mit einem rückgang
von rund 20 prozent zu bewegen
die automobilindustrie einer der großen
kunden des familienunternehmens eine
sparte mit dem die geschäfte im moment
besonders schlecht laufen immerhin
bleibt ihnen hier noch ihr zweiter
großer bereich die medizintechnik
werkzeuge für beatmungsgeräte etwa die
arbeit insgesamt trotzdem weniger jeder
situation kritisch und wie froh dass man
laufen
der maschinenbau ein wichtiger
wirtschaftszweig in deutschland mit
einem jahresumsatz von 230 milliarden
euro
der großteil davon erzielt im export und
mit mehr als einer million
arbeitsplätzen
der verband hofft nun auf ein schnelles
wiederhochfahren der wirtschaft wieder
aufmachen denken sie an verkauf von
automobilen oder technischen gütern
aber wir müssen auch auf europäischer
und weltweiter ebene die
produktionsketten und angucken und
schauen dass wir die zulieferer wieder
ans laufen kriegen
auch wenn die meisten maschinenbauer
dank erfolgreicher vorjahre die
derzeitige situation noch über wochen
oder monate durchhalten könnten die
aktuellen einschränkungen tun wie der
sportartikel gigant adidas ist auch
stark von der korona krise betroffen
weil weltweit geschäfte geschlossen sind
jetzt bekommt der konzern viel geld vom
staat nämlich eine kreditzusage der
staatseigenen kfw bank in höhe von 2,4
milliarden euro
hinzu kommen 600 millionen euro von
einem bankenkonsortium adidas
beschäftigt weltweit rund 60.000
mitarbeiter corona betrifft auch die
beschlossenen projekte der koalition
etwa die grundrente die soll eigentlich
zum jahreswechsel kommen und dabei werde
es auch bleiben stellte finanzminister
scholz von der spd heute klar
zuvor hatten unionspolitiker zeitplan
und finanzierung wieder infrage gestellt
die rentenversicherung warnt allerdings
ist
er bezweifle dass ihre it experten im
home-office die nötige software
rechtzeitig ans laufen bekommen
in krisenzeiten kommt die bundeswehr
auch im inland zum einsatz nicht nur bei
hochwasser oder waldbränden sondern eben
gerade auch jetzt weil helfende hände
und so vielen ecken fehlen
dabei übernehmen die soldaten bereiche
die früher zivildienstleistenden
vorbehalten waren
patricia schäfer auch so kann ein
bundeswehreinsatz aussehen maximilian
schreiter panzerkommandant beim dienst
in einem seniorenheim im oberfränkischen
scheßlitz seit dem osterwochenende ist
der 24 jährige feldwebel hier um hilfe
zu leisten
die haben sich alle gefreut also das
lächeln einmal an
nur leider kann ich durch den mundschutz
nicht zurück lächeln aber man sieht
ihnen auf jeden fall an dass sie dadurch
ein stück lebensqualität wir dazu
gewinnen dadurch weil jetzt auch seit
mehreren wochen keine angehörigen mehr
rein dürfen das einfach mal jemand neues
dazukommt sie sich ein bisschen mit ihm
unterhalten kann
zur unterstützung in der korona pandemie
hält die bundeswehr circa 15.000
soldaten in bereitschaft im einsatz sind
davon momentan nur ein paar hundert sie
helfen wenn die zivilen kräfte an der
erschöpfungs grenze sind unsere
pflegekräfte leisten unglaubliches
signal an die grenze und ist trotzdem
sehr oft nicht aus und es gibt viele
hilfsdienste die notwendige pflege
gerichte zu unterstützen damit die ihre
arbeit tun können weil im kreis bamberg
pflegekräfte wegen corona ausfielen
beantragte der landrat amtshilfe durch
die bundeswehr innerhalb einer woche
standen 35 soldatinnen und soldaten
bereit um in elf seniorenheimen hilfe zu
leisten
es ist und 70 helfende hände für uns es
ist unglaublich wichtig unglücklich
segensreich was hier geleistet wird
die aufgaben der soldaten im altenheim
wäsche sortieren lager auffüllen essen
ausgeben und einfach da sein
die älteren herrschaften haben mit unser
land aufgebaut wir haben lange genug
gearbeitet und denke ich deswegen sollte
man den auch was zurückgeben in corona
zeiten erscheint eben auch die
bundeswehr in einem ganz ungewohnten
licht
besondere zeiten fordern kreative ideen
erst recht am besonderen geburtstag
kalt aus er ist stolze 102 jahre alt
geworden und konnte sein glück kaum
fassen
familie freunde und nachbarn
überraschten ihn hupend mit einem auto
parade inklusive feuerwehr und polizei
eskorte benutzen wunsch bringt dieses
land wieder in ordnung das ist das was
wir wollen und wir licht und sonne
braucht der kumpel morgen wieder auf
seine kosten denn es wird wieder
sonniger und langsam auch wieder wärmer
die aussichten hat gleich gunther
tiersch für sie im heute journal um
viertel vor zehn spricht marietta slomka
mit bayerns ministerpräsident markus
söder von uns war es das haben sie noch
einen schönen abend und bis morgen wenn
sie würden auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
die neue liebe zuschauer morgen wird
wieder sonnig bei uns nur an der ostsee
ziehen noch wolkenfelder durch der
luftdruck steigt ja und damit kommt
jetzt ein hoch von großbritannien legt
sich nach mitteleuropa das ist trockenes
wetter die sonne scheint langsam kann
sich so bei uns die kühle luft erwärmen
und die regengebiete sind fern obwohl
den regen ja dringend brauchen können es
ist viel zu trocken auch heute nacht das
heißt du voltlage wolkenfelder an der
küste sonst klaren himmel und es wird
frostig in der mitte und im süden zum
teil bis minus vier grad an den küsten
bleibt es allerdings frostfrei da haben
wir dann morgen so zwölf oder 13 grad im
landesinneren geht schnell rauf auf 15
bis 18 das schon angenehmer oder auch 20
grad hier am oberrhein
es scheint die sonne den ganzen tag bis
auf den nordosten an der ostsee
da ziehen die wolkenfelder vorüber und
am nachmittag kommt dann auch dort mehr
und mehr die sonne raus bei diesem recht
kräftigen west bis nordwestwind im süden
ist der wind allerdings kaum zu spüren
ja es bleibt bei den großen temperatur
gegensätzen zwischen dem norden und dem
südwesten ab freitag und vor allem am
samstag wird es dann auch mal eisregen
den wir dringend gebrauchen können
ansonsten weiterhin trockenheit im
norden ich wünsche dir noch einen
schönen abend und machen sie's gut